qualche anno fa mi sono imbattuto nel
talento mi trovavo a trieste presso il
dipartimento di neuroscienze di un
prestigiosissimo istituto di ricerca
stavo visitando i laboratori la mia
attenzione fu catturata quasi
immediatamente da un ricercatore che era
indaffarato con una fantastica stampante
3d
all'epoca sicuramente le stampanti 3d
erano appannaggio di utilizzi
assolutamente professionali dati i costi
proibitivi per cui ero molto incuriosito
da quello che stava facendo e di cosa
c'entrassi una stampante 3d con un
dipartimento di neuroscienze
avvicinatomi scambiare quattro
chiacchiere con marco questa era allora
del ricercatore e durante queste
conversazioni
marco mi confidò di essere un archeologo
io rimasi un po basito da questa cosa e
mi chiedevo cosa c'entrassi un
archeologo con un dipartimento di
neuroscienze
marco mi spiegò che anni prima aveva
pensato ad un progetto di costruire un
drone che avrebbe utilizzato per
effettuare delle riprese aeree di siti
archeologici difficilmente raggiungibili
e in questo progetto che aveva assorbito
per tanto tempo chiese al direttore del
dipartimento di neuroscienze di poter
utilizzare in laboratorio del
dipartimento il direttore che era una
persona anzi è assolutamente una persona
illuminata diede piena disponibilità a
marco per utilizzare
per questo laboratorio e intanto che
marco utilizzava il laboratorio il
direttore lo teneva d'occhio nel senso
che notò un talento notò il talento di
marco nel costruire dispositivi che
potevano essere valorizzati
trasversalmente rispetto alle sue
competenze in un dipartimento di
neuroscienze questa sembra una cosa che
può essere anche incidentale banale però
mi colpì molto perché dietro c'era
un'intenzionalità forte da parte di
questa persona che ha intercettato
questo talento e ha dato modo a questo
talento di esprimersi in un contesto di
eccellenza internazionale
questa cosa non so come dire l'impatto
con questo talento con questa situazione
con questa nuova visione del talento non
mi lasciano indifferente per cui a un
certo punto
decisi di rimettermi in gioco anch'io
alla tenera età di 48 anni mi sono
rimesso studiare e stata una decisione
vi assicuro un po difficile perché
comunque io ho una famiglia un lavoro
degli impegni come tutte le persone
della mia età
insomma ad un certo punto si accumulano
una serie di responsabilità degli
impegni però non so come dire questa
sensazione forte di dover fare qualcosa
è stata più forte dell'inerzia data da
quelle che tante volte si sono ragioni
plausibili ma sono anche scuse per cui
dopo settimane di ragionamenti e di
valutazioni mi iscrissi provai delle
emozioni molto forti
la prima emozione fu quella di un
entusiasmo pazzesco proprio era come se
fossi tornato di 30 anni indietro no
come quando non so se è un adolescente e
ti compri il motorino
quindi ti senti gasatissimo esaltazione
dall'altra un forte senso di
preoccupazione quale era l'oggetto di
questa preoccupazione era la paura di
fare la figura del pivello
cioè io arrivato alla mia età lavoro da
vent'anni in una multinazionale nel
campo del test measure e mente insomma
sono abituato interagire con grosse
aziende anche a livello multinazionale
eccetera
mi devo rimettere in gioco in un
ambiente e in un contesto di giovani
quando io non sono più giovane inteso
anagraficamente in quel senso è
fondamentalmente avevo la paura di fare
la figura un po del pivello quindi
questa cosa mi colpì perché dico vabbè
ma è sufficiente a fermarmi no ho deciso
di correre questo rischio
durante questo percorso ho incontrato
degli ostacoli quindi degli intralci e
ho incontrato degli aiuti a tra
parentesi io ho intrapreso degli studi
in psicologia clinica
sembra che non abbiano niente a che fare
col mio lavoro ma insomma io mi occupo
di relazioni commerciali con i clienti e
vedo gente diversa ogni giorno a vari
livelli e in realtà anche qui la
trasversalità studiare le modalità di
relazione le funzionalità le
disfunzionalità questo la trasversalità
che mi aveva colpito in quel momento gli
ostacoli quali sono gli ostacoli
gli ostacoli sono per esempio darsi
degli obiettivi non realistici obiettivi
non realistici sono quegli obiettivi che
noi ci diamo in modo errato perché sono
talmente lontani da noi da essere sicuri
di non poterli raggiungere
quindi io
mi do un obiettivo che implicitamente so
già che non raggiungerò perché così o la
scusa per non fare niente
quindi cosa fece pensare all'obiettivo
finale da raggiungere poi me lo
dimentica i subito ed ha immediatamente
mi concentrai sull'obiettivo giornaliero
ogni giorno so che devo fare
tot tante volte non ci riusciva però
sapevo che dovevo recuperare in qualche
modo quindi valutare bene gli obiettivi
un altro ostacolo è quello che
tecnicamente viene definito locus of
control ovvero capire esattamente cosa
noi possiamo fare cosa dipende da noi e
cosa invece non dipende da noi ma
dipende dall'ambiente dipende dagli
accadimenti
viviamo in un periodo in cui gli
accadimenti hanno cambiato la vita di
tutti noi in modo radicale però noi
possiamo sempre fare qualcosa ed è su
quello che ci dobbiamo concentrare
concentrarsi sulla nostra sfera di
influenza e da qui immediatamente
rendersi conto che giudicarsi
negativamente ma anche positivamente per
qualcosa e per cose che non dipendono da
noi non è mai utile
dobbiamo sospendere il giudizio
paralizzante però in questo
ho avuto anche tanti aiuti
ho scoperto che ci sono delle cose che
ci aiutano a raggiungere i nostri
obiettivi che ci aiutano a valorizzare i
nostri talenti qualsiasi essi siano e
sono le emozioni
ecco questo è una cosa che poi ha avuto
modo di approfondire durante il mio
percorso di studi in particolar modo
anche durante il master di analisi
comportamentale della comunicazione non
verbale
ovvero di come noi esprimiamo le
emozioni senza le parole solo col nostro
viso le nostre microespressioni con il
nostro corpo questa teoria che è stata
messa a punto dalla dottoressa leghissa
di eurocom science
mi ha fatto molto pensare perché ci sono
tre emozioni fondamentali che ci aiutano
a muoverci in avanti e sono la paura la
rabbia e la gioia la paura intesa in
questo caso come ansia un'ansia sana non
esistono le emozioni negative quelle
positive alla paura è un'emozione che ci
fa restare vivi in tanti casi in questo
caso è l'ansia che tifa attivare sapere
che fra un mese ha una scadenza senza
ansia rischi di arrivare il giorno prima
senza aver mosso un dito
c'è un'ansia sana che tifa programmare
che tifa attivare e questo è
fondamentale
poi abbiamo la rabbia anche la rabbia
può essere un sentimento un'emozione
forte e positiva perché la rabbia e
l'emozione che non ti fa demordere
quando incontri un ostacolo e non ce la
fai la prima volta se non hai un
emozione forte che ti fa andare incontro
all'ostacolo per superarla ti fermi e la
benzina nel motore
del nostro circuito emotivo e alla fine
serve la gioia la gioia della
celebrazione della chiusura di un ciclo
ed è fondamentale chiudere un ciclo
perché ci dà la consapevolezza del
gradino che abbiamo superato quindi è
come quando io comincio a mettere il
piede su un gradino quando ho messo
anche il secondo piede mi sono elevato
di uno step in quel momento sono un po
più in alto e quindi c'è bisogno di una
celebrazione per poi ricominciare con un
secondo ciclo e quindi questa cosa mi ha
aiutato molto a capire profondamente
come le nostre emozioni ci possono
aiutare o ci possono frenare per questo
dobbiamo imparare ad ascoltarci io mi
sono reso conto che ero sordo
fondamentalmente perché le emozioni
tante volte erano solo degli elementi
disturbanti e invece no noi dobbiamo
lavorare con le nostre emozioni
dobbiamo e per lavorarci dobbiamo
capirle per capire dobbiamo ascoltarle
dando il tempo necessario per questo e
quindi cosa facciamo quando incontriamo
il talento quando ci arriva addosso come
un temporale estivo e non abbiamo
l'ombrello cosa facciamo tante volte
facciamo finta di niente perché perché
nel momento in cui lo riconosciamo
quindi quando non andiamo in negazione
niente più come prima perché dobbiamo
prendere una decisione o diamo spazio
questo talento e lo lasciamo lavorare
per noi e noi lavoriamo per spianare la
strada al talento
oppure lo ignoriamo e molto
probabilmente diventerà un rimpianto per
tutta la vita per cui niente sarà più
come prima
quindi è una grande responsabilità
riconoscere il talento e non solo i
nostri talenti ma anche quelli dei
nostri figli quelli dei nostri amici
quelli delle persone che ci sono intorno
come la scuola tutti sono arrabbiati con
la scuola di un certo punto della loro
vita io lo sono stato per ora ripensata
diversamente perché perché non si può
pretendere dalla scuola quello che noi
dobbiamo fare la scuola ci propone delle
autostrade del talento sono i template
però ai template fanno customizzati
tutti sappiamo non dobbiamo metterci del
nostro la scuola non può rivedere ogni
trasversalità lì ci dobbiamo mettere del
nostro e allora e allora c'è tanto
lavoro da fare per tutti però è un bel
lavoro è un lavoro faticoso è un lavoro
che alla fine della giornata ti fa stare
bene anche se sei stanco perché produce
secchiate di endorfine un po come quando
vai a correre no
o quando fai uno sport che ti piace
adesso la sensazione che o negli ultimi
anni è quella che ci sia stato un
grandissimo incremento di velocità in
tutte le attività
forse dato anche dal digitale devi
essere sempre reperibile
io ho un'agenda che è fittissima ogni
giorno appena accendo il computer o 80
mail cioè tanta gente che deve dire
qualcosa
forse però dobbiamo avere la forza di
lasciare uno spazio all'imprevisto
prevedere di non poter prevedere e forse
potremmo avere un appuntamento con un
talento grazia